ame
分
周りからよく聞かれる質問があります
5息抜きしてるのとかいつ寝ているの誰かです
惹かれるために毎回私は不思議でたまりませんでした
なぜなら
これがいつも私です
毎日この状態でドラマがイッキ見し
youtube の動画を見続け
それだけで一日が過ぎてしまうことも多々あります
息抜き分よりむしろ常にリラックスしている状態で毎日たっぷり寝ています
なぜそのような質問されるのかを考えた時
理由は私がこれまで様々な分野のプログラムに参加し活動してきたからだと思いました
大学で政治学を専攻する傍ら
2年生の時は他大学で宇宙のことも勉強し
その他にも英語を使って超近短やリーダーシッププログラムなどさまざまなジャンルで
活動してきました
なぜのんびりあの私がこれまで様々な活動を振るアクティブにしてこられたのか
それは
すべて自分の興味のあることだったからです
興味を持って自分の知らないことを知ろうとするのは
確約いえば自分自身のフロンティアを開拓していると言えると思います
その興味を持つきっかけは何かどのように広げるのか
興味の幅を縦と横に広げる方法はとっても簡単です
私はこれまでたった二つの方法で自分の興味を広げてきました
別府市
ふと感じた疑問を大事にする
zepp に
その疑問について調べる
自分が好きなことや興味のある分野で感じた疑問を大事にし
次に調べるだけでも良いので何かアクションを起こします
この2つのステップを積み重ねてきた経験が今の自分を形作りました
中でもよく聞かれるのが宇宙への興味についてです
なぜか大学で宇宙の勉強したのか
なぜ宇宙が好きなのか
それは幼稚園生の時にふと感じた疑問がきっかけでした
その疑問を大事にし追求しようと行動してきた結果
疑問を調べるという2つのステップを身に付き
自分の興味の幅を縦と横に広げてきました
私は山ユースベックを読むのが好きな子供でした
生物の進化や宇宙の歴史に関する絵本恐竜の図鑑などです
そんな私が通っていた幼稚園はファブリックのようちえんでした
そこで絵本で読む内容土地スターから襲われないように違いがあることに
幼い私はもやもやとした感情を抱き始めます
そして幼稚園の行き帰りの車の中である疑問を自問するようになりました
私はなぜ地球という星の陸地の日本で人間として生まれたのか
大人になった私がこの疑問をかっこよく言うとこうなります
今日は前
私は何者なのか
自分が幼稚園で抱いた前もやとした感情や疑問を当時の園長シスターに伝える土地
スターは次のようにおっしゃいました
自分の興味のあることを追求しなさい
小学校に入ると sistar の言葉の通り
自分の興味を追求していきます
宇宙に関する本や物理学視点を読むことも好きになりました
そして1冊の科学雑誌に出会います
その雑誌の中で万物の根源は素粒子であることを知りました
その時自分のいない畳に対する答えが見つかったように感じたのと同時に
広大な宇宙というマクロな世界と万物の根源
素粒子というミクロな世界とのギャップに惹かれ
小学校の卒業研究では true し物理学宇宙論をテーマになります
中学に入っても宇宙が好きだった私は
韓国航空宇宙研究一切のスペースキャンプに参加しました
東アジア各国から韓国に集まった学生と楽しく過ごし
そこで新たな疑問が生まれます
学生同士は国境を越えて仲良くなれるのに
なぜ国家間では対立が起こってしまうのだろう
この時自分の興味が宇宙から東アジアの国際関係にシフトします
大学では政治ガットを選び研究会では実際に東アジアの国際関係について学んでいます
しかしやはり大学でも宇宙のことを学びたいと思い
他大学のプログラムに1年間参加し宇宙についても勉強しました
ここで全く関係のない姓氏学と宇宙の勉強が元々は一つの向きでつながっていたことが
わかります
幼稚園生の時に抱いた小さな疑問を大切に追求していった結果
全く異なる国際政治という分野で新たな疑問を抱き
興味の幅が縦と横に広がりました
私は日本生まれ日本育ちの日本人で長期の例が二経験はありません
しかしこれまで参加した多くのプログラムは
使用言語が英語であり
昨年はアメリカ大使館で長期インターンを行っていました
今考えると私が英語を話せるようになった理由も1感じた疑問が始まりです
私の家庭は車の中では洋楽が家の中ではアメリカのドラムが常に流れていました
なので自然と洋楽が好きになりある疑問を抱きます
この歌詞の意味はなんだろう
英語の歌詞の意味を理解したいという思いから小学校の英語の授業が好きになります
少し理解できるようになってくるとアメリカのドラマのセリフと字幕の間に微妙な
ニュアンスの違いがあることに気づき
次のリムを抱きます
このセリフの意味はなんだろう
その疑問を解消していくと英語を学ぶことがますます楽しくなり
短期の海外派遣プログラムにもよく参加するようになりました
ここで先ほどの韓国でのプログラムにもつながります
大学で政治学を学んで言うと日米外交にも興味を抱きました
そこでアメリカ大使館で長期インター線として働き
現在はアンバサダーずユース関するの駅性としても活動しています
アメリカの音楽ドラマの中で何て言っているのだろうという疑問に端を発した手にこれ
下げて英語を学んでいったところに横から
姓氏学に対する興味が加わりアメリカ大使館でのインターン経験につながりました
つまり自分の興味を縦横に広げていくと今度はその広がった興味が縦横につながってき
ました
私は小中校12年間女子校に通い
そこでは全て自分たちであることが当たり前でした
つまり例えばリーダーとしてチームを求めるとき自分が女性であることを意識したこと
はありません
しかし女子高を卒業して外の世界を見てみるとそこには女性の活躍推進や女性の
リーダーシップなど女性にフォーカスした言葉を多く目にするようになりました
なぜ女性が放火しされるのか
この疑問から女性がまだまだ活躍できていない社会の現状とこれまでの女子校生活での
経験と世間とのギャップを知りました
私は中校の学生生活の中でリーダーを務める経験が多かったのですが
大学に入り就職活動を見据えて企業の求める人物像などを見てみると
リーダーシップという言葉を多く目にしました
就職してすぐチームのリーダーになったり
社長になったりするわけではないのになぜ親切にリーダーシップが求められるのか
リーダーシップとは何か
この2つの疑問が合わさり女性のリーダーシップに関するプログラムに参加するように
なります
ここで今の自分を形成する寿希也すが完成しました
りんごの部分が大学生になってから勉強活動したことです
全く関係のないように見える活動もこの地型図の中ではどこかでつながっています
それらすべての原点は自分が好きなことをしている時や日常生活の中でふと以来た疑問
でした
その疑問を大切にまずは調べる
そして参加するなどのアクションを起こし
興味を縦に追求していくと
今度は全く違う分野で興味の幅が横に広がったり
広がった興味が今度はどこかでつながったりします
そして一見すると全く関係なさそうな4つの疑問にもある一つの共通点があります
それは疑問を生み出す最初の原点が私であることです
普段の何気ない日常生活や自分のバックグラウンド自分の好きなことから疑問が生じ
ました
自分の好きなこと興味のある分野だからこそ
まずはその興味を縦に追及するというプロセスも楽しんできました
皆さんを普段自分の好きなことをしているときにふと感じる疑問があったら
まずその疑問を大事にしてみてください
そしてそれについて調べてみてください
調べようとしているとき
自分の知らないことを知ろうと何かアクションを起こしているとき
その視点で常に自分自身のフロンティアを開拓していると思います